conspiracy theorist Alex Jones is still
fighting with the legal system saying he
doesn't have the money to pay the
billions of dollars that he owes to
families of Sandy Hook victims now Jones
insisted for years that the Sandy Hook
Elementary School shooting was a
government hoax that was created to try
to influence gun control laws but juries
in Texas and Connecticut awarded the
families 1.5 billion dollars in Damages
during her hearing this week a judge
approved an order that prevents the
plaintiffs from pursuing collection of
the money while Jones and his Media
Company Free Speech systems go through
bankruptcy proceedings but on his online
show Infowars Jones insists he's nearly
broke
I have a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars under penalty of perjury there's
no hidden accounts there's nothing in
the Caymans there's nothing you know on
the moon there's nothing there's not
secret stuff there's not trust there's
none of that there's like Trust on my
house so the address isn't public but
it's not a trust hiding something but
see but the media sits there in a
multi-hour hearing here's all of that
under penalty perjury outside accounting
firms telling the judge that and you get
the complete opposite once the corporate
media gets to it he told the judge we
said Jones needs this amount to pay the
legal bills and he'll have no money
which it's a liberating feeling I kind
of feel good in this fight that I'm
going to get down to the point where I
can't buy groceries that makes me feel
actually like I've done my job I'm
actually liking this in a way I'm going
to see whether the audience supports I'm
going to see whether God wants this to
come through and if you don't want to
support we need about three hundred
thousand dollars extra in a month to
make it through the appeals and the
bankruptcy and all the stuff that's
going on that we've done the math deep
accounting we get about an extra 300 000
a month in orders in we will be able to
break even and keep the crew employee do
this if not you'll see very quickly that
I wouldn't blowing smoke up your rear
end
because unlike fauci I don't tell lies
you got that
that's my secret my brain becomes more
powerful every day because I've trained
myself not to lie to myself not to lie
to my audience and not to lie in front
of God
the Christmas lights were a nice touch
I'm not gonna lie Terry can you break
this down are these families ever going
to get their money I know eventually
they will but it could take years the
judge said the lawsuits could proceed
but the collection process is on hold
this means any appeals or pending
lawsuits they're going to go forward but
the reason the judge halted the
collection process was to protect the
remaining assets arguably Jones may have
other creditors who could take priority
even over these families so Jones filed
under chapter 11 because it allows his
company to stay in business while he's
restructuring he's now required though
to disclose his assets his liabilities
along with a complete schedule of his
income and expenditures other major
corporations like Chrysler and Kmart
they also filed under chapter 11 and
they're trying to decrease their
liabilities it may seem unfair but
they're trying to salvage the company
you know the families brought the
lawsuits not for the money so they'll
wait but they brought these lawsuits so
they could stop Jones from spreading
these vicious lies about their children
yeah Brian Judge Lopez didn't rule on
all the Motions before him but he you
know once said that one of the ones that
he's going to take up later is Jones
requesting a 1.3 million dollar salary
from Infowars parent company what's that
about so infowar's parent company Free
Speech systems they're also on the hook
in this case but they actually filed for
bankruptcy before Alex Jones did and
when they did that they reduced his pay
to uh from about 1.3 million dollars to
about half of that so what Jones is
doing is hey we're both on the hook but
I want you to pay me my full salary he's
hoping that if he can get that income he
might be able to pay off some of his
debts either you find money which is
what he's trying to do or you claim
you've got none I think this is an
attempt to try to break even uh by going
out to the parent company here's what's
interesting right he's making a direct
appeal to his fans his supporters for
money now is going to be a good test to
see how much they actually want to
support him now that the walls are
closing in unbelievable well not only
that is unbelievable listen to this more
than 600 mass shootings have happened in
the U.S just this year alone that's
according to data from the gun violence
archive well now Buffalo New York has
filed a first of its kind lawsuit to try
to stop them in their City Tuesday's
filing targets notable gun manufacturers
like Smith and Wesson Glock and
Remington the suit also targets ghost
gun manufacturers you see homemade gun
kits can be used to make hard to trace
Firearms without serial numbers the
lawsuit follows the city's race fueled
mass shooting at a grocery store in May
where 10 black people were killed the
shooter used a legally purchased AR-15
that was modified with an illegal
high-capacity magazine well the city
wants to hold gun companies accountable
for creating gun violence which
officials say is a quote public nuisance
Buffalo seeks unspecified damages in
addition to lawyer fees and welcome
everybody to Long crime daily I'm Jesse
Weber Tory Lanez May soon learn his fate
in a Los Angeles courtroom the Canadian
rap artist is accused of shooting fellow
rapper Megan the stallion more than two
years ago
closing arguments wrapped up on Thursday
and the jury filed out of to start their
deliberations Lanes whose real name is
Daystar Peterson is accused of shooting
at Megan the stallion whose real name is
Megan Pete after a party in the
Hollywood Hills back in 2020. during the
trial Megan testified that she saw Lane
shooting at her feet after she got out
of the car they were in Megan's former
assistant and friend Kelsey Harris told
the district attorney's office that she
saw Lane shoot Megan but then on the
witness stand she tried to take it back
Lance has maintained his innocence
saying he's being set up since the judge
won't allow any cameras or cell phones
in the courtroom long crime senior
reporter Megan cuniff has been inside
for us bringing us those great updates
and she says she has some concerns about
what will happen if the jury says Lanes
is guilty
if he does get convicted which is is
still a big if is the judge going to
remand him on the spot in order him
jailed which I think could be I mean I
I'm hoping the court is prepared for
that scene because that is going to be
unpleasant and very very volatile so I I
don't know how the court is prepared for
that but I mean it's what three days
before Christmas and he brings his
five-year-old son to the courthouse
being the jail him on the spot in front
of his family like that but I think when
Megan testified uh last week she made a
good point when she said that if she had
just come forward and said immediately
that Tori had shot her and not said that
she'd stepped on glass Tori would be in
jail right now and I think anyone who is
experienced in criminal defense law
would couldn't couldn't argue with that
so I think the judge is going to be
under huge pressure to remand him I mean
the prosecutors are going to ask for it
so just given the way the judges handled
the trial and kind of the way he
Shrugged off some some big issues it'll
be interesting to see how he handles
that
all right some good points there but
Megan I'm here with my co-host and
public defender Brian Buck Meyer Brian
this is a case that's been full of
contradictions retractions assumptions
what do you think of it it's hard to
keep track
it's like a maze a jigsaw puzzle it's
all that and more but the jury has the
case now the prosecution they said this
case was about a damaged ego their case
is like simple addition Megan the
stallion's testimony plus Kelsey
Harris's lying testimony plus her
recorded and candid interview plus
Kelsey's text message after the shooting
equal a guilty Tory Lanez the defense's
closing argument started on Wednesday
afternoon and continued to Thursday
morning their case is anything but
simple their case felt like algebra
eyewitness Sean Kelly said that he saw a
female fire you multiply that with
different stories from Kelsey you add in
Megan's initial statements about the
glass you subtract your testimony you
divide a missing security guard it gets
crazier and crazier the more that you go
down this Rabbit Hole the prosecution
got the last word in closing arguments
if the jury feels that they've organized
this mess it's a conviction if there's
some doubts and they're reasonable Tory
Lanez can walk yeah let me bring in
co-host and former trial Attorney Terry
Austin into the conversation this case
can be over soon where do you think the
jury stands and by the way what's your
impression of lanes you know what I
think the jury has done the math and
they have their answer and Tory Lanez is
guilty I think that he is very
self-centered and obviously he is trying
to put the blame on everyone else he's
trying to pay people off and I do
believe that you can't look at what
Kelsey Harris said because in the very
beginning she I think told the truth and
I think the jury is not going to believe
what she's trying to get away with on
the stand The Bodyguard didn't do it
he's not there so who else is left and
if you know in fact you believe what
Megan said she is telling the truth she
absolutely got an apology from Lanes so
at the end of the day you know I think
Lanes is guilty and I think the jury
will think that and by the way why did
he bring his son to the courtroom he
should not have done that I think that
that is just he's not a wise move he's
fighting two battles court of law Court
of public opinion I think that was a
good smart PR move and I think we're
going to get a verdict sooner than we
all think but I've been wrong before so
another story that's making head lines
on Thursday a cryptocurrency Founder
extradited back to the United States
this week from the Bahamas is out on
Bond and prosecutors are calling it the
biggest pre-trial Bond ever get this 250
million dollars I'm talking about Sam
Sam bankman freed who's accused of money
laundering defrauding investors and
making illegal political campaign
contributions as the head of FTX the
30-year-old crypto exchange skyrocketed
to a valuation of 32 billion dollars
getting publicities at this year's Super
Bowl and endorsements from high profile
celebrities last month though FDX filed
for bankruptcy and at least 8 billion
customer dollars vanished bangbroon
freed stepped down as CEO shortly before
the bankruptcy filing according to an
attorney for the southern district of
New York two of the founders co-workers
have already pleaded guilty to fraud
charges and they're now cooperating with
the investigation as for bankman freed
he's expected in court on Thursday for
his arraignment